good morning Hank it's Friday February
25th I'm extremely tired it's extremely
early and I'm on my way to go to the
grocery store to buy horseradish Friday
February 25th Jesus I must be really
tired either that or I've traveled
forward in time to the year 2011 it's
Tuesday February 27th Hank if you're
wondering why I'm so tired it's because
I stayed up way past my bedtime last
night why was I up so late because I was
cataloging my books on library thing
calm nerdfighters Hank before I start my
challenge I want to give you one the
challenge I want to give you is to do
something awesome with nerdfighters
there are fighters
our viewers have had some excellent
ideas for how to do this oh by the way
Sarah doesn't own any hats except for
baseball caps so I'm not going to be
wearing a hat however I will show you a
special treat don't fight the feeling
you know you won't to have a good time
and in my opinion nation the Sun is
gonna surely shine do you mean the Sun
will shine eventually because that's not
just your opinionation that's also a
reasonable assumption I mean in my
opinion ation the Sun will surely rise
and set and give off heat Hank I have
here 1 teaspoon of horseradish I've
never eaten this stuff before but sarah
says that it's gonna be pretty hard Oh
that'll wake you up in the morning
should I try to do it all at once or
should I try to just do it in little
bites all at once no I'm gonna try
little bites first you're trying to
trick me
it looks like Manning's hate man is
god it's really bad all right
I just have to do this I have to do this
after this is the worst this is worse
this is this is like waxing your chin
only longer I have this much left to it
ah I was horrible but I did it I did it
I did it oh my stomach hurts so bad oh
my god Hank I'll see you tomorrow